people catch you from every angle around
you you got to be ready for everything
you know if my face isn't ready my asset
now we just punch in his owie Ashton
you're keeping it sleep while keeping
its Sheen what do you feel like when you
put on the rain amore dress what kind of
women do you feel like it's almost like
a sculpture
around you you know his his stuff is so
sculpture but it's also not oppressive
you're not putting it on thinking this
person wants me to suffer and be very
unhappy because you're usually into the
form hugging yes yeah I'm trying to be a
bit more covered up mmm sophisticated
now you are looking insane slaying
Fashion Week I my favorite thing about
your look is it's a 360 experience
visionary because the back is great oh
hello surprise when it comes to Fashion
Week there's so much increased diversity
on the runways I like when you see that
what do you how do you feel how does it
make you feel do you know what I I get
such an amazing feeling in my summer you
see these girls who just look so much
closer to you than ya
you were ever used to really seeing a
Fashion Week you sort of want to go I'm
here for you go okay all day I'm here
for this and please please please let's
keep it moving forwards what are your
top tips for making a ground-breaking
floor role would you say always break
this tile with something different
worried like not too classy you see I
just break it with the yeah wisdom now
what is your favorite thing about London
Fashion Week on what is probably your
low light about London Fashion Week I
feel like London Fashion Week hasn't
been as diverse as New York Fashion Week
is being I think New York Fashion Week
was really about body shapes and here it
just feels like the same white skinny
girl over and over again and that's a
bit disappointing but my favorite thing
is I love watching my friends doing I
just think we should see more like
curves on the runway like it doesn't
mean that you're less fashionable
because you've got boobs in a burn more
women of color like just make it more
diverse come on
yes hot babes okay ah we are looking
bathing today I think this is a really
really good signing tip for winter yes
felt it you know dang like this bit on
the stick on my shoes a mulberry kind of
like little lake trotters but like in
Turkish yeah babe she can the city what
are your top tips the contrasting and
prim would you say I was just saying you
guys like the hula girls a little bit of
football chic today but [ __ ] very
Carlo squeal
runway chic runway see it's no in all
seriousness Martino's amazing designer a
Leakes and wearing a bit of an element s
lab so I am a Christmas hooligan
which I worship so know who I love he's
fantastic
it's got to support him and then Barbary
for tomorrow do you are kind of
fabulously extra yeah what are your top
tips are sprinkling that extra on your
wardrobe
man you got to do whatever you want with
yeah that's that's everybody's special
little taste I think everybody can go
with an outfit like this but you just
gotta have fun with it and I really feel
like your ultimate accessory is kind of
your confident oh I mean I always say
you can you can wear a trash bag but if
you can wear it well honey you would
wipe that trust
[Music]